nevertheless, there was a certain risk
when we started with it in 2018, above
all, the beginning in his
b2b business is always more difficult, you need
your first customers, that’s
difficult for us and we also got a lot of
rejections back then, but now in 2018,
i have to say  for 12 18 months i can
only remember one patch that we
lost here is a conversation
with my podcast regular
tarik müller the founder of baut juwi
mentioned, among other things, a trip to the
us symbolic impressions there but also
exciting hollywood stars at homer like
you get them and which ones are whether they
are but then there is a lot
about tarik’s experiences as a ju boss building
in times of a difficult
stock market development so the stock market price
has gone down significantly since the
ipo a few months ago what does that
do to tarik what you see in contrast  he that
at all that was a topic then made the most
diverse
cooperations last different  ten
german artists and designers from
ashraf and xpm to loredana and
bowser there is a wide range of cooperation
all of that comes up here in a conversation with
tarek müller at the end of february of
course still happy new day where have
you been all these weeks
one can also say happy new year yes  i
put our pauli in my home office here in hamburg
, in
contrast to you, as i was then allowed to perceive here on
instagram again from the moderately
, did you stay with them
celebrity super well,
or what was the topic, yes, i
was actually on the road for two weeks
also to acquire speakers for the
festival to meet customers but also
super bowl but that is the biggest
one day event in the world you can almost
say where i got it so i had the
chance to see it
live  two buddies and then
i was never the lvr and wanted to
take a look has never had anything to
do with it  gen da real people around so also here
from the podcast lukas teuchner
we have to talk about it together
after well yes exactly like the coach
who somehow makes self-made records
somehow among other things cattle and
such or earlier
only as such an artist from has he
also hangs  just around then
johann könig the gallery owner was somehow in
the usa that was so much there i was
you have to say again in detail many
many thanks to brücke you also know it
very
well i was there for dinner in the evening
actually unbelievable so what like paul
is the hottest  host
with a pareo was given as a gift i
would really cool you i had a
great evening and can only really
listen to the new podcast because this didn't happen on the pulse but he thought he studied
paul's thumbs so then i
really got to
know them in a completely different way than  you know them like
germany also as the celebrity so to
speak i thought that was really great but you
somehow have it too  ever
got to know me better negative i find it so i
love paula rauch but tell me
something about the great bowl so he how can you
imagine what it's like to sit there at the
stadium so
i can't say it for all the great
bowls in the form  because it
was very special the stadium was me
that for me there is 1 5 billion
new stadium building
medium and that scratches the thing is there
is a huge video ball or
rather as was warned
you can look at it from every seat and with it  do
you have experience in the stadium like a
cinema i.e. an imax cinema it means you
sit there you can also our luxury hotel
everything awesome chairs awesome floor
nothing dirty so really fresh
and then you look at this thing and
you’re actually already being served and then
do you have under the field in addition
than it really is
that so
maybe stand on a hose
why are you looking at a monitor
turn stadium so far i mean  a woman
isn't it really bad that there is a distraction,
so to speak, game down he
especially in football that has a lot of
breaks so the game is always the
team from a game is looking for
everything to be set up again the fans
often change a lot of breaks is not like
football runs through water and
you always have
moments like that and then this screen comes along and
there is openly
their own production school a director
their own material my analysts who
all work just for this medium
, so to speak, so it’s much more than a
scoreboard  with moving images that's
a medium of its own and i
didn't see that in the company and so
i really thought at the end we've seen the future
of live events on a large
scale so that the german stadiums
now have something like that hanging across the board that
we should have a few  it will take decades, but
that's probably how it will look like, but
that would also make sense in football
in football there is only a
quarter of an hour break ultimately what is
really impressive is that gaps are
filled in the breaks or is while
the game is going on that brings more
value this he so football you
also have 1000 so
if heldt vl are out of it or
something like that but  there's quite a bit more
value in football it's already extremely high
that you already have in other
sports it's not so maybe in
music it's somehow conceivable
but it was just for me I
had the feeling I had a completely new
experience and  i also go to
hoffmann stadiums like in london in the new
spurs stadium there recently with
donations so it's probably one of the
coolest sports stadiums in europe right now
but the new the latest thing tax
but this thing there was just with
the game so not in now  wald
himself but has the football game
and then this digital production on
the cube that was just you ca
n't do that now l  ive experience means
euro get live experience of the
digital and analogue kind at the same time
that was blatant or crazy and
i saw how do you get such a
superbowl ticket like maybe
something like that
also by the way quite interesting you
knew the relatively good buy about so
hospitality provider costs  I already have a
few thousand euros somehow
after all these years of podcast
somehow come with donations to do that now
we can do it now because the
podcasts have been going well for years and
what’s next what do we do now
I’ve spent more money but
then
From my point of view, the interesting thing about ticketing was that a
lot of Germans we met believed
you should have known tickets somewhere from
a dark channel somehow still
somehow there is still a ticket and
so the truth is in the USA there are of
course
official ones  secondary market places for
tickets so you even need them  not
somehow you can
look up official platforms
ticketmaster the day before and she is there there is a
reseller of tickets and the sold
the whole thing is called auction system
vision ebay locations but there is no
black made just someone got it and
how or you don't need it
don't want to have it and
just make money out of it throws
it officially again and then you can
officially buy time that's
so stupid in Germany because there aren't two
marketplaces in this form because
everyone always thinks it should be black market it's
like that  that's not the case and that's
why it's always possible german people who
think they have to celebrate the tessiner worried
star actually got a
work colleague the ticket in
truth that you could
even buy it cheaper than before
ticketmaster was a normal day before now
you can still buy it  do you
also want safety reasons that flights
would have to  n you don't we
bought half a year ago but we
could have bought it there the day before on site
what did you know also
falling cheaper because the two
final teams
although los angeles they come the rems
have a very small fan base and the
rascals from  cincinnati also that they
don't bring that many fans with them that's why
the ticket prices were lower when
other teams came now
final manager went up
but then we
met people in the queue in front of the stadium
who said yes I
'll come  yes from phoenix drove over it
I bought the title yesterday and that was
that so that's different then
what you think yes crass and
something else worth mentioning what is
really good is it somehow
the
stadium atmosphere vivaz video experience quasi what
surprised you maybe when  super
bowl is already such a mega event
absolutely no football fan or
follows it  not but a super castle
i look at actually but should
fall asleep a bit but that's
one i think it's important
but actually the mega event in the world
or of course world cup soccer world
team of course something else but
so pure you this this this
combination  from sports entertainment and
global broadcasting with a focus on the
usa i do believe that the number 1 event
you have so now in
parallel were an olympic
winter games
it is in comparison natural usa there
is no comparison it makes
no sense to compare it
and so what is it for  me personally
always probably we are there
again I immediately socialized you
always look super well and does he know
you because you are again and it is always
dark outside yes it has been with me for 20 years
and it was just such a great bowl and
it was light  was then somehow in the
afternoon and at the same time not tired
because I've been to the USA for a few days
But apart from that, I think it's
interesting how they managed to position
the event as so widely accepted in society
that the club also plays many different
topics. There are
awards for people who work in the
community
for people who do cool community things or for players or for people in
general who do cool community
things so somehow get involved
then he plays the army a role
that was then also quite crass
variously exemplary with the
soldiers we really do service
on land and then there was one  break
and then the people who work in the army had to or should be allowed to
stand up in each
block that was
really someone in every hole and then
two guys stood up three rows in front of me and then
everyone clapped and standard  have
you dropped a lot and gives
thoughts
and that's already a blatant
feeling and man m  erkt really
a gratitude for the deployment
of the soldiers there and also
everything about politics plays a role
all all aspects are included there of
course somehow crass music and him
with the after show and stuff and
i find that almost a bit of a shame  that there are probably
so few campfires where the
whole of society comes together that
in football, where that would actually be predestined by the
city, bringing the
worlds together like that doesn’t happen
if you say
we don’t really want that much spectacle but i
think that’s okay  still
building a platform for the future where
everything is somehow represented and
not just football so gladly just football
all year round but
there once a year at the cup final
or some kind of special occasion
you only have to play more broadly when
I  I think it's cool for the sport, but also
for society.
We don't really do that  good well good idea
never thought of it that was short
jumps i think i said at the beginning
acquire swica or what did you basically
only say but or can
or but can you reveal something
yes so let’s say
i don’t think it was an impressive appointment  while you were
in the podcast i had there is the usa the
podcast about among us here
so expect various good
appointments there is one
at the end or is with several
consequences the concrete consequence which
is actually
not yet public
but which is now signed and
i  I think I can say it here in the
pot now so please don't post
it too much explicitly
or anything dear listeners but
my colleague quentin tarantino also first of all
as a playmaker percent
who comes comes
how so what the chef so receives a
lecture or or the  stuff of the gau also
with us on the big stage conference
stage interview
and yes we asked ourselves  e is
always who it's exciting who fits and is
right so i must be able to say
tarantino the only director who
didn't even googled i also went to his
wikipedia entry
i looked at his filmography that's called i checked
every film i got from her as the
absolute mine  eyes absolutely the best
spirits there I was really can
but everyone hasn't made a lot of
films either but seen everyone
here too everything very very old yes and he
is yes and as a type also who so
crazy when met him or not at all
personally but  in the zoom kol but
you have to be a crazy crazy
so crazy positive but also crazy
somehow distanced or with your
team now also a bit special
as complex to get it done
also he doesn’t travel somehow
just alone in the business class
but there is  there were a lot of things that needed
to be clarified, because that worked out
very well on
site  now also in a podcast
so the whole nft game is relatively active also
very active and you say more than the
usual I do a bit because I'm a
celebrity were a bit involved there
is quite deep in it
and that's of course a huge
storyteller  obviously
suits us and i
'm just flashed myself that's been the case for
the last few days
so i think it also helps us a
bit that the festival is
in france at the same time there's this big film festival
meyer which now yes
i was there  was I that yes it's so cool well
I was once we did an event with lena
in cannes and I was
n't directly but indirectly
invited to
ask them I went there in the end I know
well you didn't go
we also had one  small party of the
awg of a west partys of my life
i think there and yes you
could part and tinus party sacrificed for that
i was not directly invited
sond  ern only i will only be the plus 1 only
a possible +1 yes but that
the colleague was there also in cannes
keep that is then also for the
belief in general should or should he once go
to europe a breakfast you this and
important cannes festival  agreed the
main focus is again, or
so I understood it too, but well
, I can't say everything, but
if you are and once you have
your foot in the door, there is probably
still a little something to come,
also from the American  west
we should have more speakers
most speakers is that so that
quasi son quinten tarantino
also makes other speakers
easier or was in any case
so that in any case yes that's
so fresh now that we haven't
experienced it yet so I'm me  sure that
will also be the case in the next few years,
especially in the hollywood scene once you get
to know him
and say a little bit about the country
e  it would be really cool you took good
care of me that of course you want to
do it that's later here it's
also really funny for other people too and
does he really probably
intends to stress out the king but that has to
wait and see in the end it's like that of course
with every year where even a name
alone helps of course but that's
still so fresh that's no
experience yet but it was
before when gateway chuck was still
small and then was with us until today
I tell you from time to time  usa so an
event who would like to come
if attractive for some is even really
cool the question of the
respective target group but that will be
a bit easier so for was
it now all around
really cool trip from you just say
cool
so experiencing moments and the city is really
funny because there is almost nothing
that you can do as sightseeing
then there is the observatory which you can look
over the city and  there is
beach in venice with the skate park and for us
it's all just traffic and of course you have
to hang out in houses but
then i found a few houses for a long time when a
man had found paul own
düsseldorf sold
that i don't take it back then
someone really always  guests but and you
have to live a few newport that's
so i was told that
sylt but he
'll rightly make a great
living from it and i was really
impressed and
so you can only say and he's so
complained german ambassador so  who
right now in times i think the day
before me was then somehow in kinderland
with this
plane players were there like sami
khedira there i saw and
so there was somehow everyone i was
then also traveling with luka's daughter
so it's easy he is  so to speak the
german message for everyone under 50
[laughter]
currently we taste we digress
we digress to you so
probably  I, you know, four of
them have jobs now, I suppose that's
not bad either, because it was a
bit harder now too,
with the tech title on the stock exchange overall,
so for the first time after the IPO, there's
also a bit of a headwind,
prices are under pressure everywhere
so there are no exceptions but we are experiencing
yes
i think you have to get away from it a bit
when asking how things are going the answer is the stock price
because if i were to ask myself how things are
going with us i would say i
am very satisfied we  at the beginning
of the year we gave a sales forecast,
at that time it was still assumed to be 40 to 50 percent
and
have
increased two or three times over the course of the year and so
-called guidance is now to
48 to 52 percent, which is significantly more than
we initially forecast
with a constant
loss, that means the relative
margin has also improved and that in
an environment that is indeed not
easy so the demand for fashion
is much lower than the market
expected that we are looking
down for much longer and yes the blog
is not good for the fashion trade also
for the online fashion trade  insofar
i think in a difficult
market environment we delivered more than
we promised for our million
nonetheless when i look at the
share price then you can see that
not only because it is now
i think i know about 38
percent below the issue price or 35
percent  or something like that it's
very very sad on the other hand
our investor relations team the farmers
always a slide or two slides
actually one slide for our supervisory
board people we remember with
all the other tech companies that went public in 2021
and on the
other slide we benchmark ourselves with
all listed online fashion retailers
and in the benchmark with the others  en
tech companies that went
public we do very well, so
unfortunately they came under fire,
so let's take a car 1 is
I think trade 75 percent below the top
price or something like that, there's a group of
pretty pia they do that  a
bit of what we do with the
tech segment and the software and
beauty area - 85% and i don't think there is a
text tag a large part is, so to speak,
is less than minus 50 and we
are only minus 35 million we have sunk less
than all the others reset
companies and in the fashion sector
actually looks similar so global
fashion group first zalando you
are so and those between 23 are
forgotten so our ps so there it is
like zalando and we went down about the same amount
everyone else is
more like minus 60  - 70 percent
I think that's only small consolation, so
when you say somehow everyone
else got it worse than us,
I think it's small consolation  e if we had
n't achieved this top performance
operationally, then we'll
probably also be at minus 70 - 80
percent
because like you said, the
day was massively punished and
it also took me a bit
to be honest to understand why
that is and
actually my
explanation or for how can it
actually be that basically the same
companies with the same ones pull a year
later 70 80 percent less value is
now possible for a car 14 35 percent less
because I have two three factors, so to speak, but
I believe that what many do not quite
understand  i have also heard about the
successes with you and sven, for example, this topic is
why do rising
interest rates actually have such a hard
effect on large stocks and i have
that for me is actually if you answer that in
a very simplified way
i think you can explain it like this  If
I tell you now, watch out, you'll
get a hundred euros from me in
2025 and I'll ask  what is it
worth to you today so what do you pay today
for the fact that in 5 years you will
get back 100 euros and that is
basically what big
stocks actually deal with
investors more because what analysts
do what investors do is the
try to calculate the so-called net present
value you are actually trying to calculate
what the company will last in one year two years
three years 45 years derived
from the dividends pay out that you
calculate the future so to speak yes and
the problem is the following when you say
okay you  you get 100 euros in five years
the interest rates are low and there is an
abundance of capital what the investors
then say, for example i
pay 80 190 euros today
for the option to get 100 in five years
and they leverage a large
part of it, i.e. 80 percent  it's
gap leveraged, so it's like a loan, yes, that
means you somehow have a capital
of twice 15 b  is 20 euros leverage in
the rest of the 80 give the 80 and
100 five years to get today so and what
happened now is it, so to speak, and then there
is a return is yes the delta
from 180 is 20 however that is the return on
equity is almost a must
On the other hand, the 20 euros of
equity used plus the
interest that you paid on the 80 so
now two things have happened
in the last few months, on the
one hand, the interest rate is the expected
interest rate around this 80 euros or this 60 euros, so to
speak  in this calculation 80
euros 20 euros equity 860
levitch the level of interest on what you pay on
your leverage is much higher or
it is expected that it will be much
higher in the next few years, that
is to say because of the costs for the
capital that you raise  to then
get capital back in five years have
increased significantly and the second
thing that has changed is that the
acceptance at risk i.e. di  e ask how
likely it is that
a commerce company gives 100 euros here has
dropped in four years because
generally speaking ecommerce is okay
and is a risky segment right now and
that has led to practically the
same question, namely I'll give you 100
euros  in five years what it's
actually worth to you today
has changed massively in terms of
what it's worth to investors today and
i think that i've
got the
core statement 100 euros in five years from everything fundamental so from a fundamental
yes  not changed, yes, so it has
even increased, you have to say,
now it's maybe 102 or
something, because we performed a little
better than was assumed, so
now you can say it's a
small 100, but 102, but what about these
100 euros and five  years has
changed fundamentally due to the
risk assessment, but above all due to
the increased interest burden we  what a lot of
retail investors i think i don't
know is that the purchase of shares is often
massively leveled and you
're actually
paying extremely low interest rates to this day i've dealt
with it a bit now
in the family office context
so you can  basically buy a share
one million euros and then
you get you can
lend on this share with 800,000 euros so if you
buy the etf then dax value for
example up to more than 80 percent
loan value so and then
the question is for him so that increases the
return on equity  massive if you
then suddenly earn five euros and
pay one euro in interest you have four
euros that you only have to divide by the
less equity that you
had calculated in that means but these these the
question how high the interest rates are to
finance your step leverage on
his  stock deals, so to speak, is
extremely crucial if the council actually ends
up getting
e  r is expected and not tomorrow that was
the reason why dividend stocks that just
say watch out I'll give
you 100 euros for six months got a completely different
value because if
someone told you a year ago you'll get
100 euros from me in six months what about
you  werd yes then many
investors said i do
n't want 100 euros 60 degrees negative interest yes
i want money in the future a lot of money
in the future and no money tomorrow in
times of high interest rates high yield
yield expectations and no
negative interest in the foreseeable future people will of course take it
Better money in six months than money
in five years so I remember
we still say when it comes to dividend
stocks it's foggy so that you can simply also look at the
future results that will
then be distributed the discounting has to be
yes and if that's targeted if with
a zero if we do that  now for a long
time then they are present in today's
time of the inet the
same value in the future if
you  work if interest rates had to
jump up soon, then stop paying interest to
the present day with a higher
interest rate. it has less value today
and therefore the entire investment
in this company is the future
results, so to speak, through a purchase of the
company, not simply a result in the future
is then also worth less today
simply because someone completely
external, not the company itself, you decided
in the case or with the
car now there is interest again,
your company
will be able to produce quick results or series of numbers with the payment terms or payment summer
then worth less so that's I,
I understand that exactly that is
de facto that is, so to speak, that could cash
flow calculation, so to speak, exactly
that one factor, the second factor, but
that heaven is the lever, which is the
financing of the intermediate costs, so to
speak  also a huge risk factor,
the risk
assessment for the entire segment  nt that is often
not what is done by science companies
but many dekra the
institutional investors
always talk about rotation in or out of segments
and many investors have just increased their
risk assessment on the entire fashion
ecommerce sector then
the combination of higher interest factor
of  future money higher
discounted higher between
financing costs of the loans of
your level plus higher risk and
that suddenly means that the
same company with the same goals is
suddenly worth 70 80 percent less
what makes you
independent of the entrepreneur you are going to
now in the evening going to bed with a bad feeling
or are
you worried are you thinking about it a lot
if you that's real money for you
than as a shareholder is that would
people who have now somehow
invested money built the company pale
yes  I wish it would, I wish it wouldn't
wouldn't be the case because
i can actually say we
didn't do anything wrong yes so
again we promised exactly the wrong
things nor did we
promise too much but if we
told something wrong or so yes that you also
very important so all the plans the  we
handed in just over
fulfilled none of what we
promised didn't
happen it we did exactly what
we said and we have our
plans about filters as
pretty much the only ones in the segment nevertheless
many people now have 50  percent or
not quite so if you're at the highest level
then
I think you've lost 40 percent or just 38
years that
hurts me that honestly doesn't bother me as for the
institutional yes they
have this sector as usual
which probably even rotates out
because the sector
risks and interest always smell the roast before  private
investors as well as actually annoying
as in the end, so to speak, the losers
are the private investors who realize this a
little later and that
hurts me, of course, I know a lot of
people you have invested in with us, of
course I know a lot of people who come in with
us  investing that gives me
a really, really bad feeling, so
I always hated working with someone else's
money.
I had certain investors with me
but worked with my own
money  because i
'm sorry if an
institutional investor
loses money somewhere in silicon valley yes
i can with that i think i've got it
now i can stop under the
conditions that's not
ours i saw the line was not
our fault but i can
still  a little more life because i
say that their business takes risks
and so on but m  It hurts
if I know friends I know somehow
I told everyone that doesn't work here
but they made a few people
sure I'm happy about that
too but that hurts me that
really hurts and I'm sorry but
thinks  think about it as
if things are going well yeah sure so i'm really sorry yeah
and that's a problem because a lower
share price also means
something let's say the
capital procurement costs wanted to make a capital increase
would want to draw his new capital run would that
be more expensive now or just somehow yes  and
that we are selling more shares but that is
probably not an issue at the moment
is not exactly an issue is public what
we earned so basically the coffee
from the IPO we earned over
600 million euros so that
I will be out for a while
that means no for us  the problem is operational and
not a problem for us either, nothing has gotten
worse so it's not like the
customer is now  dissatisfied but we were
ordered just when
just when there is a lot of
talk about capital markets again at the moment i think you should
n't forget that at the end of
the day the customers are behind you yes and
the question of whether a company is good and
substantial
depends on whether the end customer  happy is yes
and whether the stock market price is three times as high
or a third as high
the end customer is interested in him
not only that means operationally has no
effect i also think
the employees, so to speak, then we
don’t have any huge pain with that we
know that  we are on the right
path and everything is new but of course it's
still kind of sad
to see how three courses are going down
and that goes hand in hand with people you
know who trusted you yes
that was somehow important to me
so in the end they lost money  because
that's how it was before i didn't have any
investors on site, but we've already done
projects  t so that investors are always
on it, or customers have always made
sure that we keep our
reputation
high and just make profits for
our investors, that's why it has
worked up to now with we means alex graf von
nils also with whom i also
wife who have already done a lot, also
bavarian  builds on that so far every
investor who has done things with us
has gotten more money back yes and
now we are I think that I hope that this will of
course also be the case with
organic there but now we are
in the situation where that is  that's not the
case people got on it just
that's not exactly up to par
that just annoys me but in the end
it's a snapshot now because
counting exchange looks over the last ten years
has still gone up will
probably go up again here too
Well, at least I
wouldn't write that off yet,
maybe even for some
we don't give any tips and that's it  r not even
entry-level courses you don't know at least
if you're going to be operational now
philipp men by no means memorial the
courage that's why
it's a little talk about it 6 million taken
what you're doing with it now he's active and
since even then I already have a
business partner of hers  i
met that has now been heard
but also here through a podcast
so to speak so the lukas from tucson
german label or german
talent management did different
things has somehow i think
browser discovered somehow loredana manages
different apache and suddenly
i hear you now  you
guys on the road together funnily enough
philipp you can think about taking
a kind of mole commission we
made two investments with
people i made the first time with your
podcast clearly i didn't
invest the easiest thing
we punished one  64 have we
would invest in a lab  els in his
labor exactly and together with
lukas lukas other people you have to
say we founded a place as a joint
venture exactly that's kind of that
will have a folder has online shop for
fashion just curated from our
range plus they create they
just make brands  or do you also build brands
together with the artists, i.e. the hip-
hop artists etc. and my colleague
lukas is also really
one of the driving figures on the website and of
course he is extremely well networked, he brings
capital and so to speak
and then there is now together they
are  yes you can the purchase is of
course an online shop exactly it will be
an online shop so there will be an online
shop as a wine location there you can then
buy and there you can on the one hand
buy normal products but
get certain
brands somewhere else no idea what so ever  but curate him on
this heritage segment plus you can
buy him the products lukas and
the other people involved in it  igt are
operational, so to speak, develop together with the
artists ok so
exactly own brands so really exactly
the right brands
developed together with the artists lukas is there
you have to say although he is an artist himself
but as always much
smaller than we do in
spite of his prison tattoos on  poor but
when i met that's also quite good
that i'm cool from how far so
legendary meeting so we made an
appointment we never
saw each other in person before we only text but talked and
then we wanted to post the evening on the job
then i would  it to the set
boulevard in hollywood what we
were meeting there was nearby has a
studio or was working and then
a guy drove towards me in his
black convertible mustang on something like that and then a pair of
golden glasses and so
extremely casual and then me  am lukas was
yes i am glad that you got something
so greetings from we also know
what our street credibility yes it is
that's not it, that's not how it will be with
us,
that means there's a
shop with a wide variety of artists who
come from the area and then the other
topic, so ashraf, another,
separate topic, but also here in the
podcast people, a young label
but upstream  you can say now
from germany to the younger ones
that's why, yes,
that they wanted to do the financing
round and contacted us
and i'll be excited about it because
i can really do that from the podcast,
well, and so we also have the article
read through and i mean i read that
too the the article i do
n't think i know what the headline
somehow what this young man sold
three minutes somehow makes a lot of
money definitely in a very short time
with brackets his jobs
naturally refuses as a headliner  so of
course I looked at the article and
dad's mega traffic jam how they do it, so
6pm is such a thing  a super cool brand
yes stuff we're miles
away from being able to both wear our style
level around 6pm
and what they do is they
always sell it in drops
and you get a community code to
even get access to the job and
to get these codes and
penetrate the ashraf on instagram like that
and the stuff is always
sold out super fast yes well he really made
millions in sales and then that
was so funny then we looked
at it jannati d'elegance but there
was also a value the  were so they
have been since this company existed
i don't know how many minutes only
live yes so they
do about this job and in three
minutes the hall is sold out is
amazing or to hunt then current
with shopware the shop will soon be closed again
yes so i have that  now look at it that
's the way it is in the don't do any performance
marketing tv spots and that's the way it
goes against everything I'm basically in
mei  learned a trade in these
18 years of ecommerce school yes and then
i see something just so okay it is
thought completely differently and that
is of course super interesting yes if
people do their business so differently contrary to
everyone escaped everything you do in this
normal  e-commerce school you're
actually learning to build up so they
're successful nonetheless, honestly, he
has local, almost earthly
problems, yes, we have to internationalize the vaults,
that's with the shop,
I was all a bit difficult,
the logistics aren't quite up to speed,
the pigs aren't being
processed properly  the little bit of help from the
supply chain yes and of course
that was our moment besides capital
we can help with everything with
scale we now have technology that
we have implemented in many online shops
that
is also well-aligned for that fast
internationalization faster time  to
market we also have one
logistics we also offer something gay
now and in that respect it was
actually a cool match i think
we understand the business of course
very well done needed operative
partner who
heaves the whole thing to the next level the pants
whatever the means i can do that  I that
I don't know I can't
say now so I don't know if that
would be cool now for people to say okay
also understand that you're doing
something together with a wide variety of sources in
the end it's maybe all
marketing nothing just somehow
then yes  indirectly admits again for today
as they acquired contact data
address
contact data addresses not at all so there
are by no means the tournament really
seriously not well for us
on the one hand is a good customer for the money
also a reference customer so to speak
on the other hand we are also just
seriously interested in
fashion brands like you  construction means that you can experience it up
close and s  o
getting to know a guy like punished is now also
easy to experience yes
for me it is also a free free
seminar in a way yes
plus of course we are interested in
the goods if creates
somehow decides
to expand the distribution at some point of
course the goods then too
for sale on youtube, of course,
but i also believe that it is really
a good investment, so i believe
that the
team manages to build something that is significant and
that in the end the value of the company is
increased, so it's not just
marketing for us now  or something like that but there
will be I think there will be created so
whoever wants to scroll
back a bit in the podcast is I
think it was maybe 1 34 ago we
made it so your ear is too
small the world in munich was hit back then
I did the podcast with
wirtschaft so you just have to do that
last year  being otherwise
said almost a few times in the scale
i think i have somewhere a
bill from the plattner i either heard at the
doppelganger or where he does his stock market
calculation or he actually says
with a view to the
coming i meanwhile
don't care at all would himself  it's
worth investing with you because you've also had
a one-day play, so to speak, for more than
necklaces that's basically what i think
if i understand a shop software
with a wide variety of additional
competencies that you can book and
you then sell it in the company as an organic
product  others out there end up having
their own shops fire or their own 2k
or something
and they now have to offer the walter
pilz and there were also suppliers
has it up it’s a fair way of
looking at it to say that alone
is already worth so much  should
actually somehow come to me that if
you're only worth a little bit
then that's okay  the rating
is already it's already clearly too
low it's going so well that the money
so sky is going very well at first
maybe for the listener who didn't
get it because that's not
what we've marketed mega broadly so
we've had ten in since 2008  of the deeds in the
segment that is shown in our financial
reporting under teck media
darling among other things there are
a few other things in it but in the
segment not only skis and we have we have
actually been offering our software to third parties since 2008 ten at the core that
is  actually a headless enterprise
shop software with which you
can ultimately do e-commerce adscale yes,
customers from 10 between 10 million and a
few billion are already large
and yes, classically it is the case
that we replace SAP and salesforce
, they actually hold the oligopoly  in the
enterprise shop software market and yes,
next to us there is also commerce tools
, I also have it here  Listening to you in the
podcast, I also found
the founder there very good and the
speaker I call that it's the
whole shop software enterprise world,
you have to say yes, then there's still a
shop, but they're actually rather
small in the enterprise segment, so it's
actually amazing how  there is little
competition in a
market worth billions and i'm not talking about
billions in sales but billions of
professionals who are achieved there in this
market and exactly how have we been
active since 2008 by offering our software
we have kept it relatively flat the
balver we actually as  when we
started we were so overwhelmed by customers
that we still don't have a sales
team and actually
haven't
done that much marketing until now we were always more
or less at the limit
if customers could answer directly
we now have over 100  online
shops so from when he made for the shop
but i also have s  already a few times
a roll so an advertise how
slow going
because but also point out that i
i know that your content not
only does the job and trade
access online marketing the logistics
to guess and exactly exactly exactly so
we  offer so the core is
the shop software there is usually
a reason why the customers come to us
yes because we usually solve a
relatively large number of problems for them how creates
problem also yes to the
internationalization the born
software is much easier than with
others  rather already in there we
have already localized so many countries
simply because we do that
anyway there is also a global shipping with
the property developer and shipped to 126 countries
26 languages from localized payment liegl
everything he already picture in that means inter
ationalization soft topic what the c
stomers  do you want to become a market place
? you can do that
quite well with our software. you
want  en on marketplaces sell
their own products maybe on
zalando amazon otto bohl whatever
lists that works quite well with our platform
we have quite a lot of romney
channel features where we connect offline and
online because we have a lot of
customers there too i think we
have  a larger set of features than
most others and the core commerce processes, so to speak, have been
solved very well
, that means you can connect several
bookers you can make intelligent pricing
relatively easy personalization
and today you know how much
sales are made in the segment with this
topic  so the tm segment had
such a
postponed fiscal
year in the last fiscal year, it was more than a year ago that
sales were 84 million and this has grown by well over 100 percent in the first
nine months, so in the past
nine
months, so let's be
clear about that  well over 100 million
sales in this segment  escape and that
is an essential game that
is is he with y
awesome game with psion based on board
june such business have turnover
said pilz they are completely different from
e commerce arena partly by way
not factor 2 345 something like that ever
after how it grows but
then suddenly there is a factor of 20, yes, there are visitors
, there is a factor of 100, so yes, the
ones with tips are different, to be fair
, I have to say that I just wanted
to go into that, so I don’t know if
I went into it like that, and that also means
just mentioned, in addition to the technology
, we also offer logistics for customers
that do the logistics for them and
performance marketing and we do
that because the customers often
come to us with these use cases i want
to sell them internationally they become your marketplace magna and so on  what we
found is we say
super cool and technology can do the three
month implementation project bern bern
there it works  let's go and then when advertising three
months later the thing is live and then
we hear our logistics
unfortunately still need three years yes that's
why at some point I started to offer
other parts of the value chain in the im, so to speak,
namely logistics namely
performance marketing because then the
next thing is the loci the  logistics has
now finally managed it again
three years to find google ch manager for
france let's say that's how our
business model is because we calculate
on the sales basis that means we
have a total interest that
our customers are successful and
ultimately the logistics the
online  marketing additional service why
do i say that because not the complete
scan sales is technology yes that means
you get these crazy multiples of
course on the pure technology
sales it's called that's what enrico in
greven said but it's very seldom
explained that's why it's not that
is that  it's not yet at a hundred
million  n or something like that yes, i
can build a complete master i ca
n't say any numbers but that is
significant so how we are
now even one of the
big enterprise shop software players worldwide
and i think we can
keep up quite well with the spreader commercetools
& co and a few ago i think
i had quite a momentum so i
gained quite a lot and that although i
still remember it started in 2018 and
we had the podcast as a threesome,
i mean between and then
it said to be he has it really often
in and after that he was right, had
to say yes, but then he said he
would focus eleven he would
n't do it because saying that makes it better
only core ecowas and there has already been a
hindsight somehow lost his eye
yes, that's exactly what I think too  well i
think you can now say
that this is a great success and we
believe very strongly in it i think the
success will also w  still be very
big i believe that a total
value driver for our company
and i what i have observed above all is
that platforms are monetizing more and more
parts of their value
chain yes and that they ultimately make the
scaling of their infrastructure
available to third parties too
he is millions involved
of course easy on there has group does
it in the professional area with in trinity they
also have a solution similar to money
and yes zalando I think you will
I would be surprised if that didn’t
happen at some point they also do it
with tradebyte and so on  to establish
security as a solution provider in this
industry and yes
i believe that we have i believe that
what was there, so to speak, what was back then
i believe the real distance is
that we never saw ourselves as fashion e-commerce
players yes, if sven
says  focused on your core business
is the question what actually is
our core business our core dna right from the start we
always saw ourselves as a
technology and data
company that can
handle transactions efficiently that's why the step for us was
actually to say ok then
somehow let parts of our
infrastructure be made available to you we
weren't like that at all  big how it
might have been perceived from the outside at the time
, even when it was
n’t so normal that you have
additional business, yes, and amazon, as
I said, now, what are they
doing, cars and what I do streaming
and so on, so that cannot
explain it  with that's somehow e-
commerce platforms that make
smaller ones not only that amazon as a
big player that massa that's why
this step wasn't that big for us
and i still think there was a
certain risk when we started with it up to 2018
in front of everyone  things is the
beginning in his company it's getting
harder and harder you need you  because the first
customers are difficult for us and
we also got a lot of rejections back then 2018
but now i have to say for 12 18
months i can only remember one patch
that we lost yes so
now it's actually like that the customers who
deal with us  employ is but a
few income most of us do
n’t have the publishers
i can’t say that we
publishers aren’t so aware of
our customers
right now because a little bit by telling them in the podcast
doesn’t wake up sleeping dogs
so
it was too late he has  as difficult
as publisher I've actually been doing the
whole incredible thing in the last 6 12
months but you're
not just here in the podcast but in
general someone who definitely tries things out in
public and
I always think that's really awesome a new adventure
and I have that  a few weeks ago
we saw that in the
team-internal whatsapp what tarik müller
is about on toll road  ßen beds so
that must also
say a resignation not everyone knows that is a
reddot community so that saves on the
platform lives like the German
actually wanted reid betz from
Germany or it is made for Germany
and very funny the wall street
mauerstraße as a mason  street bets and the
Germans too everything a so a
trademark look in there and so there
are no english words and where is
everything about you now so how are
there things about you
we are coming so
a colleague of mine told me he was a
bit of a gamer  and he left me
that then sent a due diligence
primary street bets is about us yes
about
you the number of competitors will be drawn to the
rhine and then I just
commented like that against haye really cool
if you have any questions then write me
really ten  seconds later but i
banned and
violence or this is so so a
[ __ ] here has registered here more
here supposedly something  like tarik müller
with his fake account and so on
that just annoyed me so much that
i wrote him an e-mail
saying i'm not a fake account and
then i got fired up again and
because i'm not part of the community
so never  you could post
there again and he posted a bit
and i think that the funny community
yes i definitely had fun
and then someone from the
community contacted me and
asked if i could join the podcast
and i have a  a little bit off the
hook yes said now actually also
with the podcast which was always very
funny also because the community asked
that he was definitely very very very
funny questions very funny how very
funny people there but it's a
bit like that at the moment
probably not if new standard of
capital market communication that's a
bit too high but also like
my colleague florian rinke article
g  Wrote
to your he about the fact that not only you are
now on reddit and there,
so to speak, actively speaking with the investors
or those interested in the title, so not
only the products from the EUR share
, but also Herbert Diess
from VW, so that’s also the
progressive one  it's also so you can see
german cios from
listed companies betting on the streets for a few weeks
with comments and so
actually yeah that doesn't make for
course maintenance so i'll do that
while the server goes down but i'll do
it a bit monolingually fun
at the  sache i think he
probably has a bit more
strategy behind this
i would like to guess first of all
because you also sadly have to
realize that the so-called
private retail investors are not really
price-moving, so that's the way it is
with such large stocks as a tesla or
so if now the whole world to all
retail investors out  the way in the
world basically do something so
that's course-moving yes or the
wall street bezzel gamestop is particularly important
because it has relatively little
liquidity so you
can already move a lot with little effort but
unfortunately you have to say our course
is not  driven by the
private investors but still like i
have over two billion and say yes
our course is driven by the
institutional investors so i
do it for the fun of the street
batman thing i had
recently or we make relatively few
investments in the acquisition  we invested internally in
my company and his name is the
director ritchie, they do the
marketing of shops, so that means
amazon, he now has huge
business, the whole amazon can place ads
and yes, it's almost
like google placed ads on the
platform, it's the same with you  a
topic so you make it logical that
you yourself or is that already w  because it's
just very, very great sales is
similar to what it is now at scake com
next to the existing business what he and
does in retail say ok where can
I build up more sales again is an
advertising topic he's full so I saw
this development live on
amazon  i've been working with alex nils i
think we want to be a
bit of a fouling investor from a
company called factor they
ultimately
specialized in neo and amazon they
basically took the customers and they
sell on amazon and people
just give them  advertising for the auf so
that's all 56 years ago
i didn't have anything but of course looked pretty closely
at what was happening retail media
it's called that a bit on the
internet and how it's been for
many years yes that's it for us  also
a simple business comes the 43 yes
that is relevant so we both
have not
discussed the topic right now but yes  actually i
just worked three weeks ago arek i
'm doing that together with you guys action
podcast exactly the american podcast
episode number 12 or something like tamedia
with our retail media manager marie
christin you here so who if the
topic is interested retail media should
be i think  listening to the last episode
of christa regt etc. that was really
cool 45 minutes like tamedia talked
also called a bit of numbers and so
on so definitely a
relevant business field and we
didn't discuss this cross
advertising here but it's full of cross advertising in
that respect  yes but it would be sporty
but i personally think the topic is
pretty cool what we did, among other
things, that we
finally set up an auction system
that means you can as a brand we're looking
at you're now somehow adidas
or something then you can now somewhere
go there and ultimately you can
offer your individual products yes and it is e  in the
auction system ultimately and with that
you can ultimately boost your position on the
product list page
yes almost everyone from amazon knows that
except for something else you
can sort of see the sponsored article
in there and we also did
that the tool we built last week
and have that  I was also
looked after personally very closely because I
grew up with google adwords 15 16 17
years ago I earned my money with google adwords then I
actually built my business on it so
at some point I switched from the facebook system
and did a lot of
business there too  founded companies
and then with factor he also
noticed that amazon auction system and
actually for me such a small
childhood dream yaman auction system so
an inventory option but you have the
head position is exactly is of course
super cool and
now they really have a mini google
adwords because ultimately built where adidas
and we think it's meanwhile
really dozens of brands besides
ultimately being able to book your advertising about it
okay okay
let's say again bottom across advertising across
advertising in bases of the word
at the superbowl i did
n't see the tv advertising because i was at the
stadium but there was  this huge
story is here from colin base who is crazy about this
qr code
for you so exactly when is coming
also very aggressive marketing that
's stayed overnight so here too
tv advertising with quark or
just and bigwigs let's get something like
that i don't know  whether it was
worth it for them I somehow have the good
for the calculation where everyone calculates how
awesome the 20 million downloads or
so I read but I
didn't go up in trading or like
something like no fear so I
'm sure it was  it's i want
to be sure it was a good
creative so the whole calculation that can
now read how great it all is  it
worked in the end i would have
hated it the bitcoin price is going up so if
it had gone really well the next day the bitcoin price would have been
somehow 5
percent higher because it all depends on the
tv of course bild kreuzer
should what do you buy with kombi
but that was it  is not the case of
course that would be too crass is so
definitely i wish i had
had the idea but i think now i'm
the second i
don't know what was even cooler that they got you
with it now
so in the marketing industry yes so
certainly now they would but i
mean there are a lot of people sitting there now
who watch the super bowl and
advertising for that really doesn't matter
in germany even more so on the tv
and if you're there soon at do
n't know somehow in the advertising of yukos
or  or somewhere else at prosieben where it
was circulating yes yes yes i do
n't know if that doesn't have the even more special
effect that each  he knows the super
well advertising is how crass and so
a lot of attention is me
then qr code i mean it breaks out like that
everyone makes spots expensive for millions yes
and then counter brought qr code for 60
and that's so out of line me
I'm just wondering if it was a bit
successful it was just so
completely out of line and unexpected
then you have this effect even if you read
a book like that with guys or is it
just really cool I do
n't think we'll do it anymore  that
's not our style now either, which is very
blunt to copy but i found
it for this casecon bases
some day nördlingen i think more tikis
scanning qr-code than now somehow
fashion girls without it being our
target group so i thought  stop for
their target group, especially with
this super bowl where everyone's
attention is probably the whole
world reported about it was extremely
clever, by the way, I still have m  al
after there was a bit of
the is combase they also celebrated for what they did
now
and he pushed it through in the end and
I think you only do something like that
if you are a founder yourself and expect that
you would probably
push it through with you  I'm
horny we're going to do that now but it's amazing
typical example where I imagine
if you now in the classic group
how a lot of people have to justify
themselves and also
have a certain respect for the idea of making a mistake from the bike and t
at's how it co
es at the end  not through
so that's a great idea but you can
ok yes to make dollars yes yes 100 percent
so that's her after in freedom the
only reasons have them completely crazy
that she so I mean what did that
do I think then six seconds
spot well then  yes it means almost a
second back
so i say something around 10
million of our think so you see
i think the people 20
i also read it again
but forgot
if it was ten or twenty mean that in the
end if he voted 20 minutes there the
20 minutes would be loose it yes who is a
euro per download but is the dollar
so that would be that would be a very  good
acquisition price i would say where i
'm pretty sure you have to look
now how many of the downloads also
convert and
so on of course in the end see how much water
the customer acquisition costs but
also the bass tina has caused
the pr that we are talking about  and so
on so that's all
followed up again so i think it was
a highly efficient campaign and it was
highly efficient because it
completely broke the pattern
and i
think you can allow yourself to just completely
break the pattern  that is of course
difficult for managers of another company
where i now talk a lot with my
colleagues their editorial colleagues
about it  I'm talking about those who come from the
trade but do pretty crazy things in marketing, in
addition to gaming, china is
mandatory in all matches and there is a
very aggressive model, but I
think you're constantly on the top spots in the download charts worldwide  for that well i think it
's interesting that i'm still here
on my cell phone from time to time I also send what
feels like 300 push messages a day
so very very aggressive crm very
aggressive so e-mails bush everything so
for the listener there is not decided
is finally  such a desire for fashion
maybe no idea so in any
case cheap goods so
work also extremely cheap so at a
reasonable price at the end of the day
does not serve our core
segment you have to say well I think we don’t have
it now so we see less of
one  there is a risk that our customers will
migrate to china of course we
always measure these issues i somehow i think i
now  m the cheap segment would be
then I want to worry more
about what's going on because it's
already
very, very large, this very, very
covered, so I think it was founded by
a Chinese who, however,
at some point, I think
, was educated in America,
lives and they are too  not active in china at all
as far as i know they
produce in china but
actually only sell outside of china
so the problem is
you don't find that much
information at all but i do
n't really want to know which
investors are behind it or what percentage of it is  because they
are actually trying to keep everything secret
i have heard
rumors that seemed to
want to go public sometime soon in the
next few years anyway i
don't know yet how reliable
the rumors are but if that were the
case  definitely an
extremely interesting prospectus oswald is
quite a phenomenon  so it actually seemed to
be among the top downloads so
we're talking about all categories
across all countries so really
almost all countries are very very
successful what it's
total [ __ ] under sustainability
criteria just say yes the stuff really does come through
sometimes too
just flown straight here from china well
so delivery times of 10 12 17 days
hold up because it's really super cheap i
've already ordered there of course
to take a look at it so i do
n't have any mega high demands as to what clothes
are going for myself yes that's
really right  blatantly cheap shows
but
that's what I get so I think it's
done well it's kind of
on is a little different again
yes it's a kind of sell
that you don't see in these classic western
apps like that it's not coming
anyway  points to collect circle on
people totally blatant open pointstotal game
we fashion style ultra penetrant im
crm also do a lot with influenza is
where i also turn to so also
very social media i leave a lot tik tok
last the extremely ticker classic in
your marketing is quite interesting what are your thoughts now
maybe somehow post or andy me
it says  yes, post-pandemic soon, they
should be relaxed even more that's
a topic, yes, of course we're asking ourselves
how do we deal with the whole
work situation if, well, I think
my mind, on the 20th, the home
office obligation is abolished and somehow
even occurs  in the emi then
the question is what is actually because
the post co will regulations our posco
wants regulations looks like we have
to come to the office on tuesday wednesday and thursday
and monday and friday are
remote days that means you can go to the
you want to go to the office but you
don't have to and the idea is that because
tuesday wednesday thursday the
internal appointments are closed  at least also
take place in the conference room again in
person not hybrid because then
almost everyone is there and that you then have meetings that have to
take place via video
call because not everyone will be there
then the question is when you can
even do this with the post
government is starting but will
also remain completely remote, for example, yes, that you can
almost always have meetings on Monday and Friday
via video call, so
even sitting in the office is
probably more or less the
whole day in the way. I
think most people will be on Monday
come to the office on friday evening so that
means our regulations are basically non it
comes tuesday wednesday thursday has to come to the
office and monday friday the fashion
accordingly i want to assume
90 percent of the people will work from
home on monday and friday which
in turn is on from remote
and so we organize an event twice a
year or at least twice a year
in ha  mburg where everyone
will do it there we will meet in the hotel three four
days then there will be a party in the team event team
retro is sort of in there are also
stand ups with the entire it department meet
and greet with other teams
and so on that is a  a bit of the
idea that we currently have, so in the end it
will cost you or will the
change cost 2, it's permanently less
and three again exactly like before and
we can also imagine maybe
at some point saying there are two office
says and three remote yes, so we  believe
roughly fifty fifty so that what we are
striving for and 50 50 can
produce it now so start with 3 2 that's
not 50 50 it's 60 40 and either
we then go there and
say complete february is
remote yes or  we'll go there at some point
and say maybe two office days
three remote so we have to see
we actually believe in
hybrid 50 50 50 offices 50 remote in the long term, which
we avoid though  n want in this 55
the world is that everyone is
in the office on other days and you are actually
in hybrid meetings all the time where
two three people sit in the conference room
and two three people are connected via video
because that’s what
happens to me, I think so  personally for
wörsdorf as yes as diesel hybrid
meetings that's why we said
okay we believe in fifty fifty in the
non it in it we believe in from
remote in the 9 we believe in 50 50 and
we'll solve fifty fifty over these three
days  office two days remote and then
a full month remote or like
homann wechsel is then also a developer
i mean i would go along with
that they are partly their fashion
so you often work
together with developers not based in
hamburg so only used to here
didn't have before either but
it's a couple want to go to the office as
i mean they can move towards us
so remote doesn't mean you are
broker instrument means a  subject it is
optional so the developers
we also want a lot of development teams office
so they can also as a book
okay so we even go as far as we
have even set up tecops in the
meantime that we not only have
for the tech people so we
not only have  in hamburg now
in the office but we are also opening
three offices abroad just for the
tech although the remote are
currently very much in eastern europe as the german market leader again when he is back
yes that will be
a very well known brand and there are
a lot of developers there
we already have some developers and exactly
how does the tecdax do the work
two remotely but many actually want to
be able to come to the office
yes and whoever is in hamburg can come to the hamburg
office whoever is in one of
these three countries can
then go to the office there  ok but it does
n't have to be that it's just the solution
rihm's idea but as you
think the system is now er  first time out of the way
that i encourage myself a bit
we want to pull off a big thing
live and in full color here in
the exhibition halls on 17 18 yes yes
that's why all the speakers
spoke diamonds or if i
told you that the teleplan so you
think there  first of all the topic
is not through it but i think
that we have been for two years now,
our office has been staffed by five
percent or something like that basically nobody there 85 percent or something like that a home
office and i think that we are
now in
conferences can take place in the next few months and that
we can bring everyone back to the office
in these three days,
i think it's over,
i don't think so, so we'll have to
continue struggling with it and i think it'll be
interesting next
fall  what will happen then but i
am at least confident that we
will somehow slowly move
into this phase in march april may  where you can build such
hybrid setups that people come into the
office i am convinced that
the conference can take place and of course the
hygiene requirements are not quite
as they used to be i would assume now but
i am pretty sure that
it can take place and then you have to
I think I'll see how it developed in
autumn, but I'm
not a virologist and I've been there
countless times,
well, okay, so we want to see
each
other
I say
how I haven't gotten that far yet the topic will
probably be announced to us in a similar way so there
's no other way to do it there wo
n't be a developer anymore if you
're not full enough yes I think that
's generally the future it  allowed by
quite a lot of companies in the it sector
has now digital young companies
that arises on its own
the question remains  us as a creative company, so to speak,
where a lot of things can also be created in an
informative, informal way on the floor and
so and
that if there is a model what
you do I haven’t
finished it yet we could also discuss it with my colleagues
here
so what are going
in that direction somehow you have now
somehow exactly the
last three days of the week are free or whether you somehow decide ad hoc and we rely on it you're just like three days in the
office then but that's going to mean that
you never all always know yes  that's well
known little office space is
other people meet up yes so of course you have
the advantage of less office space at all
but the question is yes
why do you want to call people back at all
and i
think that's what the people here always think  why
we want people back into the profession
is because we believe that
humor is not so productive or or we
trust people i  it's
not all right i trust the people that
the people work at home i think to focus
on these four productive but that
the problem is creativity and that's
thinking
outside the box this informal noticing of topics from
other teams i think that's the thing
really suffers yes and that's why i
think totally i think for
saab working on topics home office is the
most efficient system so but i think
companies like you companies like us we
live from the fact that people are creative and
come up with crazy [ __ ] like qr code
through the tv  i
'm almost sure i'd almost
bet that an idea like that can't come about in a
video call center or it
's less likely it's just like that because
i think it has for creative
processes it's kind of easy because
you see each other and also a little bit of
small talk  well and somehow this
chat the man before after the appointment
actually had an efficient no but  which
leads to innovation and this too,
running through fluorine and
somehow overhearing someone else over the coffee machine at
some point and
thus staying up to date with what’s going on
in the other departments
visually seeing which teams are getting bigger
which teams are getting smaller i believe
that  a lot happens in the office, which
is actually
inefficient for you, so not productive in the
sense of working through topics, but
a lot happens, which actually leads to
creativity and innovation and
that's why we
want to bring these two three people into the office
days a week is not that we
believe that office work is more productive
it is that we believe that office work is more
creative more innovative and
like that plus the people in the
company have just informed eight
about what is going on
okay okay okay so again a really big
trip now again until the  close
then briefly the topic again or there
is do  ch hardly any podcast without but only
briefly and finally
we don't want to avoid it in the future
we didn't talk about a few topics
the lake nearby
I think somehow the area we
live stream a bit ahead of
me I also wanted to ask my
colleagues  people have him on live
streams of others because he
talks everything about it i've got it on my list if
we've been around for a long time and you
just addressed it briefly you
also do it meanwhile let's
call it a kind of structure how you
invest your money  is or how he as a
founder makes an investment now after all the
successes of the last few years what how do
you do that clever but also an
idea to jump out of it so there is
reason to come up in a few weeks maybe
somehow if it almost always crosses the rhine
to see and then
at the very latest but maybe we'll get
it before we've managed to
do it in any case yes
I'm always happy to be here all
right as a clown endanger many thanks and
I hope we got rich stuff about
it for all who
listened for a hairdresser hat ryan duncan
[applause]
[music]